I'm ready  Amber  [Music]  if you're out there and you're listening  but also worried about you  nothing wrong  we're gonna find a way out of this  I can't let it die I'm not gonna let it  die  my name is Amber chesborough and I'm  being held against my will in Venezuela  want answers she's his wife she's my  sister we're desperate for something  I'm gonna go down there take care of  your sister we don't need money this is  a political stuff don't worry about it  brother and my husband are in Special  Forces  I know how these decisions are made they  want to prove a raid  we have to get her up  I guess we should cancel dinner  how many lives are you willing to trade  for your sister  CIA wants a war and you're going to give  it to them  the truth is democracy is dead in North  America we reject your influence  of our rescue they can't find this place  you don't know my family  [Music]